êtes vous prêt à voir une nouvelle image
de moi que vous ne pourrai jamais
oublier
on va regarder ensemble mais toute
première vidéo alors je vous vois venir
oui il ya d'autres youtuber qui ont déjà
fait ça j'ai vu un petit peu d'eau du
gua montrent effectivement leur première
vidéo gens regardez c'était il ya deux
ans au lala attendait regarder de quoi
je parle
voici ma première vidéo que j'ai postée
sur internet
il y à 12 ans 12 ans il ya des jeunes
qui regarde cette vidéo actuellement qui
sont plus jeunes que cette vidéo vous
voyez un petit peu le délire en faisant
cette vidéo je le reconnais j'ai
l'impression d'être le michel drucker de
youtube j'ai commencé il ya très long
déjà c'était sur dailymotion s'est
trouvé des gens savent pas ce que c'est
c'est le minitel de youtube celle de
youtube créée par des français qui a
jamais marché du coup c'était il ya
douze ans je découvre dailymotion
youtube on peut poster des vidéos je
vois le caméscope de mes parents je vois
un câble devant mon ordinateur je dis un
moyen de faire quelque chose qu'est ce
que je peux encore de l'humour non un
court métrage noms de l'animation pas du
tout ma première vidéo est une vidéo de
gaming
je suis un joueur dans l'âme effet créé
tellement route à l'époque que je
filmais ma nintendo ds pour présenter un
jeu japonais c'est ma toute première
vidéo
je n'ai pas envie de vous montrer ça
mais c'est pas grave on y va quand même
salut s'allume alors je vais te poser
une question c'est qu'est ce que wayne
donne bon j'espère que ça va marcher
parce que j'espère que cela va marcher
alors j'ai plutôt end entier parce que
c'est en fait j'ai fait cette vidéo dans
l'unique but de montrer que j'avais un
logiciel pirate sur la nintendo ds l'axé
en train de montrer et dire voilà je
peux télécharger des jeux japonais etc
c'était ma manière de la raconter un
petit peu c'est un jeu de musique qui
est excellent au passage tout ce que je
vais faire c'est jouer un [ __ ] de jeu
et je me rappelle très bien de la fin de
cette vidéo
elles descendent dangereusement la pile
donc voilà ça tombe bien donc sous les
bons parlant de windows
c'est un jeu sur ds ma console s'est
éteinte je fais une vidéo avec une
console décharger à quoi ça sert on voit
un bout du trépied là avec le caméscope
de mes parents très souvent on me
demande si rien est ce que tu pensais
devenir youtuber etc
quand tu t'es lancé mais bien sûr que
non pas qu'on soit c'est un pendant que
je jouais je le mets en ligne je
n'imaginais pas en faire mon métier un
jour je n'avais aucune rigueur pour ça
si encore des commentaires sur un an il
ya plus de commentaires sur dailymotion
a supprimé les commentaires je pense que
si ça ne marche pas dailymotion ce aussi
un petit peu à cause d'eux
miniatures de vidéo en dessous on peut
les voir elles ont toutes été supprimés
ils ont supprimé les miniatures ils se
disent comme ça les gens ils cliquent
savent pas ce que c'est quelle est ma
deuxième vidéo que je poste sur internet
de la fiction non un sketch non pas du
gaming
non ma deuxième vidéo s'appelle poum
tchak babble ou la pire titre ever voici
le cadrage de des parents dans le sud de
la france je suis assis dans le fond la
qualité c'est du quatre cas ça on est un
peu à la manière du test du jeu vidéo là
c'est que c'est dû tourner et monter
cirque a pas de cut là ça fait on entend
le guitariste dire l'aca film au début
la sapn la safim cancéreuses comme ça
oui je me rappelle c'était au lycée et
on avait un mur pour poster un peu des
annonces et cherche un guitariste
cherche un batteur etc et alex que j'ai
peut-être croisé trois fois dans ma vie
on avait décidé d'essayer de faire voix
la guitare grattant sans moi je faisais
de la batterie lui faisait la guitare et
ça a été immortalisée à l'ex big up a
toi
[ __ ] j'accélère deux sont les rêves à
l'époque c'est de jouer à des jeux vidéo
toute ta vie ou et star du rock je suis
en short avec des vieilles asics
flinguer là avec un mec j'ai rencontré
il ya deux heures une musique on n'a
jamais répéter ensemble c'était pas du
tout préparé c'était il ya douze ans je
ne savais pas que j'allais film est
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'autres
choses
eh ben ça passe par ça ça passe par
essayer de bricoler un petit peu à
gauche à droite pourquoi pas du gai ni
pourquoi pas de la musique
à l'époque tout me semblait possible
bref ce n'est pas terminée sur mes
toutes premières vidéos loin de là ma
première vidéo on voit pas deuxième
vidéo je suis en petit grand comme ça
dans des pixels fond du garage je vais
enfin sur la troisième vidéo montrer le
potentiel de mon physique avantageux je
me filme dans la chambre et découvrir ma
chambre de l'époque et je crois que vous
ne verrez plus jamais de la même manière
ça va piquer les yeux attention âmes
sensibles s'abstenir
bonjour bonsoir c'est monsieur dream
aujourd'hui je fais part de mes coups de
gueule par où commencer
c'est la première fois que je me tienne
réellement je suis l'homme le plus
coincé de la planète
philippe rochot c'est monsieur dream se
c'était mon pseudo pierre pseudo pour
jour c'est moi c'est monsieur dream
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous parler est
un truc on laisse ce ballet de ton qu il
y avait mes parents qui étaient pas loin
dans la chambre d'à côté ou dans le
couloir et du coup je voulais faire ça
en secrète du genre si personne ne
pouvait passer à côté de ma porte et
m'entendre pour que je sois le moins
humilié possible ça m'arrangerait j'ai
la lampe de mon bureau dans la gueule
rien ne va et derrière on découvre un
petit peu mais la petite chambre d'ado
avec des posters avec des meufs à moitié
à poil les mangas les meufs à moitié à
poil c'était mon obsession à l'époque et
la thématique de cette vidéo en fait je
faisais du dessin sur tablette graphique
est en fait le style et ne marchait plus
j'ai dû en racheter un ça coûtait genre
presque 100 euros j'étais dégoûté et du
coup je me suis dit tiens c'est
exactement un sujet qui intéresse les
gens
[ __ ] mais encore une vidéo sans
montage on me voit à la fin en train
d'éteindre la caméra nouvelle vidéo là
c'est bon j'ai été piqué il fallait que
je fasse des vidéos très régulièrement
même si c'était flinguer comme ça si je
suis chaud thé mais j'étais tellement
content de pouvoir poster ça sur
internet et 2
dire qu'est ce que je vais pouvoir faire
après pas bonjour c'est le mot du jour
m waouh quel montage professionnel et de
déception ont déjà fait que vous le dis
j'ai monté avec windows movie maker qui
est le logiciel de montage pour les
enfants pour les foetus le truc que tu
as gratuitement sur ton ordinateur
windows d'où les effets incroyable le
mot qui arrive amertume qui barn tu vois
je racontais un truc de merde genre je
voulais rencontrer quelqu'un mais j'ai
pas pu le rencontrer moi que c'est un
truc absolument pas du tout passionnant
mais c'est plus pour parler encore à
nouveau de la décoration de ma piaule
pour montrer que j'étais un peu à un ado
à droite encore une meuf manga dans son
lit mes couilles là et à gauche
j'avais un poster the simpl life ça
c'est ce simpl life c'est une télé
réalité avec paris s'il tonne et 8,9
bref qu'ils sont deux américaines pété
de thunes et qui décident de voyager
je me suis dit [ __ ] de meuf à moitié à
poil bien je vais mettre ça dans ma
chambre je n'ai jamais vu cette émission
je viens d'apprendre n'ya pas longtemps
qu'elle était le concept de l'émission
c'est des meufs
elles vont à la ferme est ce pour ça
qu'il ya une fourche et tout mais
j'étais trop con des hormones faisait
j'assume et pas trop mes lunettes je
sais pas pourquoi et déjà à l'époque à
17 18 ans j'avais déjà delà de la barre
mais là encore je me rasais de temps en
temps mais ce que savait pas c'est que
ça l'ait poussé un peu partout bref je
commençais à faire de plus en plus de
vidéos de sang vu 300 vues toujours
filmé dans ma piaule à larache etc
je me suis dit tiens je deviens
professionnel avec le caméscope de mes
parents qu'est ce qu'il me faudrait a
généré un générique
je n'ai pas de logiciel de 3d je ne sais
pas faire de graphisme je n'ai rien
d'autre si ce n'est au caméscope
je vais vous montrer qu'elle a été
l'introduction de la vidéo pendant
peut-être 12 tu as ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta monsieur dream maître de
l'animation c'est moi hayao miyazaki y
sauter dessus
il est comme ça il fait mondiaux
alors je voulais créer un générique j'ai
filmé une ardoise qui est à l'envers
jalu logo et j'ai juste dessiné des
trucs et j'avais vraiment j'ai de la
roumanie quoi et j'ai été fier de ça je
m'étais ce générique de main à chaque
fois devant mes vidéos c'est incroyable
je n'ai plus jamais fait d'animation
apprécié cette vidéo monsieur dream eaux
après je rappelle monsieur dream c'est
mon pseudo je me cachais derrière une
identité secrète
là j'étais à aix en provence je venais
d'arriver à la fac donc je pense que je
vais avoir tout juste 18 ans et je suis
passé dans la presse et je déchire voilà
c'est ma nouvelle caméra donc mon
caméscope vidéo aujourd'hui pour les
gros plans larges comment je commence à
me ressemble et plus floues oui
franchement ça me ressemble et oui je
suis passé dans le dernier fh éléments
dont ça se passe ici ici mais surtout et
si tu blagues incroyable je monte le
monde pour en fait c'était derrière
c'était dans le magazine fhm pour ceux
qui savent pas c'est un magazine avec
des sujets en tout genre mais surtout
des meufs à moitié à poil je rappelle
j'étais un pervers sexuel allaient paca
est toujours dans la légalité n'est ce
pas et ça parlait de en fait de l'iphone
l'iphone venait d'arriver et ça c'est
très drôle parce qu'en fait j'avais fait
à l'époque mon premier buzz c'était une
vidéo je parle de l'iphone l'iphone
venait d'être annoncée je le sais il ya
des enfants qui regardent pour l'iphone
ça a toujours existé mais non c'est un
peu mon minitel à moi ok j'avais fait
une vidéo dessus tout que je vous montre
l'iphone donc j'ai complètement craqué
pour ce produit car c'est le téléphone
portable plus complet qu'il existe
blague
incroyable j'avais imprimer une photo de
l'iphone qui venait juste d'être annoncé
et je l'avais collés sur des du cloud
avant de commencer les détails avec nick
j'aimerais quand même souligner sa très
petite taille et son extrême discrétion
logo apple s'il y avait un truc qui
avaient un oeil donc j'avais fait comme
si c'était le logo prends tu es moi
[ __ ] wahaha mise en scène incroyable
je regrette je portais ce genre de
chemise avait claqué 600 euros dans un
objet pourri j'ai rêvé que je claquais
600 euros dans un objet pourri mais mon
petit cyprien situe servait ce que tu as
les mettre dans un smartphone bon pote
et en fait je passe ma vidéo à le
démonter jeudi
de quoi y avait pas la 3g dessus je suis
si peu visionnaire c'est incroyable je
regarde l'iphone je fais non ça marchera
jamais 223 me lever en vue dailymotion
c'est l'équivalent de gangnam style ne
s'est pas prononcé gamme dane style
c'était un buzz monumental
là je commence à avoir un peu ma routine
et cgc de m'éclater un petit peu voyez
des démontages des trucs à des cats qui
avait pas du tout au début toujours s'y
trouver des trucs un petit peu créatif
commandes amusé par exemple là j'avais
fabriqué un paper toys une petite
figurine en papier que les gens peuvent
faire que j'avais customisé avec une
gueule qui ne me ressemble pas du tout
je vous montre à quoi ça ressemble à la
fin j'adorerais faire ce genre de truc
un petit peu improbable avec du papier
des trucs j'avais déjà fait des t-shirts
je vais vendu sur ebay y'avait genre
cinq pièces avaient fait des stickers
aussi des stickers ou les gens
m'envoyait une enveloppe pré timbrée à
leur nom et moi je mettais les stickers
de dans les enveloppes repartez mais en
tout cas ça m'éclate et donc de faire
des dessins de créer des choses et
d'avoir une interaction avec la
communauté
si aujourd'hui je fais pareil je
recevrai je pense un peu trop d'
enveloppe pour un seul homme mais ce
n'est pas la seule chose un petit peu
folichonne fille folle voilà je faisais
des bouillet un peu chelou
ok je suis là je chante et voit le
résultat
ok aa c'est moi c'est rien atteint
prendre la place chez le numéro un
on entend ça roule ne sais pas
s'il vous plaît voilà ce genre de trucs
qui n'ont aucun sens qui ont fait quand
même 22000 vu le cv vidéo de méchoui ce
qui était à la mode c'était de faire des
cv vidéo pour essayer de trouver un
boulot et j'avais parodier ça on voit là
je disais ouais moi je suis super g
devant la tour eiffel exploit réalisé
mon cv vidéo ouais
est ce qu'il y avait des blagues de dans
la nature jeu ok d'accord way genre
j'aime la nature chez un bisou un arbre
puis sur les chiottes
je fais aussi de la vidéo sur internet
j'ai déjà réalisé plusieurs courts
métrages l'humour ça se travaille
c'était le genre de vidéos je faisais ya
dix ans je commençais petit à petit à
faire de plus en plus de vidéos face
caméra même si c'est des vidéos de merde
mais c'est des vidéos qui que
j'affectionne particulièrement dix ans
c'est énorme quand même on se rend pas
compte du temps qui passe c'est ouf on
va terminer avec un des petits trucs
[Musique]
ah c'était un site au pouvoir faire des
bruits avec son clavier j'avais tourné
ce truc là j'ai mon ancien employeur à
20minutes.fr ça existe encore génial on
va se terminer là dessus merci d'avoir
regardé cette petite review des vidéos
qui te met mal à l'aise parce que tu es
jeune et inexpérimenté bien évidemment
désolé pour tout le malaise que je vous
ai procurer mais pour moi je suis est
dégoûté et attendri par moi même c'est
marrant c'est un sentiment très étrange
pour des trouver un mot français pour ça
on se dit ah très vite c'était une
petite vidéo comme ça en mode schyle
parce que je suis en train de travailler
sur mon prochain court-métrage que je
tourne bientôt au japon dans quelques
semaines
et donc voilà je voulais déjà interagir
un petit peu avec vous avec des petits
souvenirs malaise en moi je vous dis à
très vite
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
[Musique]